This morning,
I asked my toddlers what they wanted for breakfast,
and they both said cereal.
So cereal it was.
And we got started right away.
I made two types of cereal.
The first one was chocolate chip cookie cereal.
So I mix some flour,
peanut butter,
maple syrup,
milk and chocolate
and form that into a dough.
Then I rolled tiny little balls
and flattened them out to resemble little cookies.
I put all of them on a baking sheet
and then pop that in the oven for about
10 to 13 minutes.
Pulled that out
and let that cool
while I started on my second type of cereal.
The cereal was a Cocoa Puffs cereal.
So I did oat flour,
maple syrup,
cocoa powder,
some nut butter,
and gave that a really good mix.
Then I form that into a ball,
cut that in four pieces,
and then started assembling my small
little Cocoa Puff balls.
I didn't wanna flatten these out,
so I just laid them on the baking sheet like this
and put those in the oven as well for about 10 minutes.
Once those were done,
I let those cool as well,
and then assembled my little bowl of cereal
with my Cocoa Puffs
and my cookies,
topped that with milk,
and that's what they had for breakfast.